BuzzFeed's big Trump scoop implodes the
media bachi hit on Christian high school
students and the media try to target me
with selective editing this show is
going to be lit today this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
well for those who don't know the term
lit is something that the kids say these
days it means that things are going to
get hot I mean I'm a little angry a
little angry over this weekend I have a
few words to say about the media's
awfulness about their general inability
to do anything remotely approaching
telling the truth I can't wait to get
started but you can because first we
have to talk about how you invest so the
fact is there's a great article that
just came out in the LA Times about
market volatility driving investors back
to traditional havens things like gold
and bonds maybe it's time for you to
diversify right maybe you should be
looking at diversifying your savings
plan and people you should be looking to
for precious metal purchases Birch gold
group right now thanks to a little-known
IRS tax law you can even move your IRA
or eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver go check them
out right now look back historically
when the bottom falls out of everything
else Gold tends to safeguard savings
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews when a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau right now contact
Birch gold group and get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals see if diversifying into gold and
silver makes some sense for you this
comprehensive 16-page kit reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move that IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA if that's something
that you're interested in doing to get
that no cost and no obligation kit go to
birchgold.com slash bend that is indeed
birchgold.com /ban was more let them
know we sent you birchgold.com slash Ben
all right so let me begin today's show
by noting that the media are a flaming
dumpster of hot garbage in the media are
terrible at their damn jobs I mean
terrible at their jobs because it turns
out that many of them are not interested
in being honest now this is not every
member of the media there's some members
of the media who I am sure interested in
being honest but for the media it is all
about jumping to conclusions about
creating the clickable piece about
ensuring that they are the first on a
story even if they are dead wrong on the
story and we saw this over and over and
over over the last 72 hours multiple
stories the media put out or outright
false outright false at the very least
they were biased twisted selectively
edited I haven't seen a weekend this bad
for the media in a long time and it's
disgusting it's disgusting because let's
start with the March for Life okay not
with me the March for Life we'll get to
that but let's start with the March for
Life here's what hap
the marshal life I was there on Friday
and there were hundreds of thousands of
people there some low-end estimates put
it like 150 to 200 thousand some
high-end estimates I heard headed it
like six hundred thousand suffice it to
say you could not see the end of the
crowd it was the biggest crowd I have
personally ever seen it was unbelievably
large the mood was positive people were
excited people were uplifted people were
upbeat it was an amazing amazing event
did the media cover any of that to the
media cover how amazing the event was
the size of the crowd the incredible
fact that hundreds of thousands of
people showed up to defend the lives of
the unborn in the middle of the winter
with no pending legislation on the table
did the media bother to cover any of the
actual amazing things about the Marshall
life no they manufactured stories
deliberately so they would not have to
talk about that instead they have a
narrative that they have preconceived
and that they're going to bang into the
ground and that narrative is that
pro-lifers are evil that people who are
white are evil that people who are
christian are evil right this is the
narrative and they are going to hit that
narrative as hard as they can over and
over and over and it doesn't matter who
gets stuck in the crossfire it doesn't
matter whether it is a bunch of
Christian high school students so late
on Friday afternoon as Sabbath is is
falling I start seeing online there's
some talk about Covington high school
which is a Catholic High School
Covington Catholic High School in
Kentucky and I don't really pay much
attention to it it's about to be Sabbath
it's been a really long day with a lot
of mixed emotions as we'll get to in a
little while and I kind of signed off
her Sabbath I come back on on Saturday
night and the world is lit the world is
on fire why because they're saying that
these kids from Covington Catholic High
School were harassing a Native American
man and the reason they're saying this
is because the Native American man went
on national TV in lied about it because
he said that these kids surrounded him
and tried to intimidate him and that he
was there defending a group of black
Israelites which is to say a cult that
exists in New York City mostly they call
themselves the offspring of the Jews but
they really have nothing to do with
Judaism it's it's a cultish vegan weird
thing anyway these folks showed up and
they started harassing the high school
students in reality but the way that
this guy portrayed it on national TV was
that the high school students these
white high school students some of whom
were wearing baggy hats were supposedly
harassing the black Israelites and then
this guy stepped in and defended them
and for that he was
basically intimidated and he's an older
Native American guy I think he's in his
70s and he'd served in World War two and
so the media treated him with all sorts
of respect so here's the original video
we're gonna start from the very
beginning here's the original video that
the media put out of this confrontation
the original video is cut from a two
hour long tape hey the two hour long
tape as we will talk about shows the
precise reverse of what the media said
happened because they're cuz they're
damn liars
because they're damned liars and they
knew full well they should wait for the
for the full story to come out and they
did not wait for the full story to come
out there are a lot of people on the
right some people who I'm friends with
who jumped on this and started talking
about how the kids were guilty and I can
only get upset with them a little bit
because the fact is that they were
assumed in good faith on the part of the
media that is always a mistake as was
reiterated to us over the last weekend
you cannot grant you wonder why
President Trump is popular when he says
the media suck at their jobs it's
because they do suck at their jobs hey
their pre-existing suckage was there
long before President Trump came along
you want to know why so many people in
the middle of the country resonate to
President Trump when he rips on the
media because they deserve every last
iota of it for coverage like this so
here's the original video that was put
out by members of the media and there
were headlines across the board first of
all let me just say this this is not a
national news story
no violence was done to this guy there
was no physical harm it was a con even
if the media had told it the way that it
actually happened that's not a national
news story it's a bunch of high school
high schoolers acting like jerk-offs
right that's it last time I checked high
schoolers acting like jerk-offs is not a
national news story but in any case even
assume that the media are telling the
truth it's not national but here's the
video they showed and it turns out this
is wildly out of context as we will see
so here is here's the original video
they show that's supposed to tell the
whole story about these evil white high
school students wearing Magga hats
mocking laughing at this Native American
guy surrounding him and harassing him
then you can't see this there's a guy
standing in the middle of the crowd he's
banging on a drum and the kids are
chanting along with him and it looks
like they're mocking him there's one kid
who's standing directly in front of him
and he just kind of smiling awkwardly
and some of the kids are laughing and
videotaping okay and it looks bad like
on the face of it it looks like these
kids are mocking the guy or that there
is something to or they're attempting to
laugh at the guy or something like that
okay and everybody goes nuts how could
they do this first of all nothing bad
happened to the guy there's no violence
done to the guy really now gonna punish
not at school like you suspend the kid
at school if he does something like this
but we're gonna it on in national media
Doc's these kids for something like that
so here is the so here is the reaction
the reaction to just the video alone the
reaction to just the video alone is the
is is razor a razor ass land of CNN he
tweets out honest question have you ever
seen a more punchable face than this
kids this kids like 16 years old he is
literally standing there literally
standing there smiling a little bit
because it's an awkward situation how
would you feel if there was a guy
banging the drum in your face raisa
Ashland says this kid's face is
punchable how delightful how delightful
and then Howard Dean tweeted out this
where the former head of the DNC
Covington Catholic High School seems
like a hate factory to me why not just
close it
check out this thread I hate factory
I hate factory now let me just say I do
not think that it is any coincidence
that on the same weekend the media
decided to go after Karen pence for
teaching it at a Christian school that
the head former head of the DNC is
suggesting that Christian schools should
be shut down as hate factories that's
not a coincidence
in the media the far left in this
country the increasing mainstream of the
Democratic Party
they hate religious people hate them
with a passion if this were just a
normal high school not a Catholic High
School you think howardino reacts quite
the same way hey then there's this
reporter a reporter for Huffington Post
which Huffington Post again is just a
manure pile of journalism they don't
even attempt to do journalism they just
they're their moveon.org
under another name so the guy's name is
Christopher Mathias and he puts up a
photo of this kid
smiling next to a photo of white kids
pouring drinks and ketchup on lunch
counter protesters in the Inn in
Birmingham in 1960 as though these are
equivalent in any way so this kid is now
a segregationist this kid is now a KKK
style segregationist and then a BuzzFeed
reporter tweeted this out about these
kids a picture of the kid in the maggot
hat you're standing there again he
didn't do anything he's just standing
there he didn't mock the guy into
anything and in fact as we'll see this
kid went when when somebody tried to
start confronting the Native American
guy this kid turned around and tried to
stop it okay but this is they put up a
picture this is this reporter from the
this reporter from BuzzFeed put up a
picture of this kid next to a picture of
Brett Kavanaugh and wrote one theme of
the conversations over the past 24 hours
equals how deeply familiar this look is
it's the look of white patriarchy of
course but that familiarity that
banality is part of what prompts the
visceral reaction this isn't spectacular
it's life in America so in other words a
white kid smiling is the look of white
patriarchy just like Brett Kavanaugh who
they accused of gang rape falsely by the
way just astonishing astonishing stuff
and then a reporter from The New York
Times put out a tweet like this a
reporter from the New York Times it's
not this tweet we all find it in there
there's a there's a reporter from the
New York Times we actually put up a
tweet quoting a Facebook post by someone
named Marlon James why I've never heard
of and here is what the statement says
that the New York Times reporter
endorses okay you ready for this here's
the thing about Covington Catholic
school boy he didn't shout he didn't
rage he didn't threaten he did not even
lift a finger because he's not even 20
years old and already knows he never has
to he just stood there with his smirk
the whines ceiling his white privilege a
smirk saying that nothing you speak
matters your existence doesn't matter
your protest doesn't matter your dignity
doesn't matter not even the fact that
you were here first matters you're a
joke because I find you funny you're a
target because I got my bull's eye on
you and you are nothing because I won't
even remember you by the time I get home
this is racism boiled down to the core
bigotry in excelsis an editor at The New
York Times tweeted out that this was a
well spoken objection to this kid again
even in the original video all the kids
doing is standing there now here's part
the problem this guy the this Native
American guy lied to the mainstream
media I mean there are a lot of people
who are pussyfooting around what the guy
did he lied okay this is not a mistake
he didn't make a mistake in describing
the situation he outright lied about the
situation on national television and to
the Washington Post and everybody bought
it and pretended it was okay because
he's an older gentleman who served in
World War two lies our lies no matter
who speaks them if you're not willing to
call out lies then you are not doing
your job as a journalist speak truth to
power to democracy dies in darkness all
these media liars we'll get to that in
just one second first we needed to talk
about how you can save time and money
here's an easy way to save time and
money and a cool down right now go
online shopping when you do make sure
that you use honey you've probably heard
me talk about honey it's the free
amazing browser edition extension that
automatically helps me save money on all
my favorite sites I wouldn't be doing my
job if I didn't tell you how honey makes
even Amazon better with their millions
of sellers on Amazon using the same
products how do you know you're getting
the best price honey does the shopping
for you as you shop on Amazon honey's
best price finder automatically compares
the prices of millions of sellers that
carry the item you want honey even
factors in shipping sales tax
Amazon Prime status to make sure you're
getting the lowest total price I use
honey all the time and I particularly
like using it for Amazon because as you
know I'm a huge Amazon fan I'm an Amazon
Prime customer and honey makes my
shopping that much cheaper when I go to
honey and we buy there are too many
products for me to describe each
individual one that I buy from Amazon
like we buy everything from Amazon we
probably saved hundreds of dollars by
using honey at this point the next time
you are shopping on Amazon treat
yourself to a free upgrade that
guarantees you always get the absolute
best price add honey for free at join
honey calm slash Ben that's join honey
calm / ban honey is the smart shopping
assistant that helps you save time and
money the honey again join honey calm /
Ben all right so here is what Phillips
told the newspaper and then we will see
that there is video footage that shows
he is lying so he says that he he
accused the teens of harassing and
intimidating him and it claimed the
scene grew ugly he said it was getting
ugly and I was thinking I've got to find
myself an exit out of this situation and
finish my song at the Lincoln Memorial I
started going that way and that guy in
the Hat stood in my way and we were at
an impasse he just blocked my way and he
wouldn't allow me to retreat and as
you'll see from the tape this is just an
outright lie
he then accused the teens of chanting
build the wall the tape is two hours
long there's not a single instance of
anyone shouting build the wall and
hurling racial epithets at the group of
Native Americans the tape is widely
available it is two hours long there's
not a single epithet shouted in Native
American not one he also accuses the
teens of shouting racial epithets at the
black Hebrew Israelites or standing
nearby in fact it turns out precisely
the reverse the black Hebrew Israelites
are shouting epithets at the kids
there's one black kid from Covington
Catholic High and the black Hebrew
Israelites are shouting the n-word at
him the kids are the problem hey then he
went on CNN and he lied about it here he
was talking about
I love the CNN calls it the
heartbreaking viral video here is this
this Native American guy Phillips a liar
lying on CNN standing there and I've
seen that group of people in front of me
and I seen the angry faces and and all
of that I realized I had put myself in a
really dangerous situation all that
anger and all that wanting to have the
freedom to just rip me apart you know
that was scary
this young feller put himself in front
of me and wouldn't move okay so this is
just a lie it's just not true he can
move to the right he can move to the
left he can reverse out he walked into
the crowd so here's the actual tape now
you're wondering so I keep saying that
he's lying here is the actual tape
several segments beginning with black
Israelites shouting slurs at the student
shouting at a black student and then you
will see Phillips approach the crowd and
walk into the middle of the crowd the
crowd did not surround him the crowd did
not mob him nothing like that he walked
into the middle of the crowd singing and
chanting walked directly up to the
student you saw in the original tape and
then started banging his drum in the
students face here is what it actually
here's what actually happened that the
media refused to cover because they're
they're liars
degrees was paint offered a blood set of
slavery your houses everything your
parents home was given to you by the
bloodshed of people he said this race is
what the hell is all is right what the
hell
what the hell is you sear crackers will
make America great okay the kids don't
do anything right the kids are doing
nothing and then you will see I mean we
weed there's tape of it of Phillips
walking into the middle of the crowd and
banging his drum right in this kid's
face and there's another piece of tape
in which the kids turns around and tries
to actually stop another kid from having
an argument with Phillips because
Phillips is shouting then all these
white kids should go back to Europe at
one point or it wasn't I think it was
one of Phillips his friends who is
shouting at somebody that's not how the
media covered it it's not and we'll get
to the students statements about this
which are a lot more true than anything
Phillips had to say in just one sec so
here is what the the student said first
of all all these folks online started
trying to Doc's the kids so Kathy
Griffin Doc's means find their personal
information and put it out publicly so
Kathy Griffin put out a statement saying
these kids deserve to be doxed their 15
year old 16 year old kids who didn't do
anything and she's saying now you may
say these kids who are a little bit rude
you may say that these kids shouldn't
have been making faces in the tape how
are we going to pretend that this is the
great crime of the century are we going
to pretend that this wasn't a
manufactured media live from the very
outset is that all we're gonna pretend
now we're gonna pretend that these kids
decided to mob a Native American guy
when precisely the opposite is the case
that I've walked into the middle of the
crowd to confront people banged his drum
in a kid's face while black Hebrew
Israelites were shouting at people do we
have the tape of the guy walking into
the crowd let's play that see here he
comes banging the drum right now there's
plenty of room for him to go to the
Lincoln Memorial without walking through
these kids plenty of room here he comes
he's walking into the middle of the
crowd with the bunch of dancing friends
of his banging the drum walking into the
middle of the crowd he deliberately
sought out the crowd walked into the
middle of it more supposed to believe
that the kids wouldn't let him move
through mobs him and scared him nonsense
it's a lie
hey and then what happened is because of
all the daxing they actually went after
the wrong people because they don't care
now I'm old enough to remember when
Laura Ingram was boycotted for
critiquing in my old fashioned David hog
for saying that David hog was whiny and
she was boycotted I said was a dumb
comment at the time but was it boycott
weren't they of course not it was absurd
okay David hog was what but he was he
was untouchable the Parkland kids if you
said anything about the Parkland kids
even saying they didn't know what they
were talking about on guns even saying
they have a right to speak out they went
through something terrible but they
don't know what they're talking about
even this was considered uncouth the
entire left mobilized to destroy these
kids destroy them for doing nothing so
far as I can tell that is even remotely
worthy of this sort of reaction Andrew
Hodge is the brother of one of these
kids okay and here's what he wrote
yesterday was supposed to be a day of
celebration for my middle brother Alex
who got married last night instead my
family had to deal with the fallout of
my youngest brother Michael Hodge being
falsely accused for standing and smiling
in front of an indigenous man with a
drum people then proceeded to spam my
family with harassment and threats of
physical violence we then find out our
parents address was posted online if
that wasn't enough our family operated
business has been slandered and attacked
no one reviews evidence or does any due
diligence they immediately escalate
things to a state of frenzy over much of
nothing the zealots screamed for the
head of Michael Hodge knowing that there
will be zero consequences to them if
anything happens to him my parents
uncles aunts receive messages stating
that they're pieces of bleep parents and
won't be able to protect Michael Hodge
forever seriously what kind of behavior
is this Michael Hodge is the best kid I
know he volunteers for Special Olympics
took them skiing this Thursday is
involved in the church youth group
doesn't drink smoke volunteer for
drug-free Clubs of America and is in the
spy ring chef Michael the people then
started circulating articles of him
regarding his dreams and goals of being
a chef
find the college's he plans on attending
and proceeded to blow them up
encouraging them to rescind to offer and
calling him a racist POS piece of bleep
you reach out saying how terrible of a
family we are two famous threatened us
and you know nothing about us yet you
circulate the information and spam us
like it is the only truth that has ever
existed in your lives you condemn my
parents for being horrible role models
yet you jump to conclusions and we're
ready to string up an innocent dude is
that what you are teaching your children
and family I sure hope not it saddens me
people have nothing better to
- on Saturday then scoured the internet
for drama and then dig up info on a
family and rile up an army to attack
them hold yourselves to a higher
standard set a better example for your
sphere of influence we will all be
better off for it nobody's gonna do that
by the way quick correction Phillips the
Native American guide the center is a
Vietnam vet not a World War two vet just
want to correct that for the record
because when we screw something up on
the show we try to correct it I'm like
members of the media who keep doubling
down hey then the kid who's at the
center of all this the kid who did
something terribly terribly wrong by
apparently standing there while I bang
the drum in his face that could put out
a statement - and here's what his
statement says quote I am providing this
factual account of what happened on
Friday afternoon at the Lincoln Memorial
to correct misinformation and outright
lies being spread about my family and me
I'm the student in the video who was
confronted by the Native American
protester I arrived at the Lincoln
Memorial at 4:30 p.m. I was told to be
there by 5:30 p.m. when our busses were
due to leave Washington for the trip
back to Kentucky we had been attending
the March for Life rally and then it
split up into small groups to do
sightseeing when we arrived we noticed
for African American protestors who were
also on the steps of the Lincoln
Memorial Rights nick-san man this is the
Covington student in the middle of the
controversy I'm not sure what they were
protesting and I did not interact with
them I did hear them directly direct
derogatory insults at our school group
the protesters said hateful things they
called us racist bigots white crackers F
words meaning insult for gay people and
incest kids they also taunted an African
American student from my school by
telling him that we would harvest his
organs I have no idea what that insult
means but it was startling to hear
because we were being loudly attacked
and taunted in public a student in our
group asked one of our teacher
chaperones for permission to begin our
school spirit chance to counter the
hateful things that were being shouted
in our group the chants are commonly
used at sporting events they're all
positive in nature and sound like what
you would hear at any high school our
chaperone gave us permission to use our
school chants we would not have done
that without obtaining permission from
the adults in charge of our group that's
the chanting you're seeing the kids
doing they're not chanting to mock the
guy all they are doing is singing their
high school sound a song in order to
drown out the racist stupidity being
shouted at them and no time did I hear
any student chants anything other than
the school spirit chants I did not
witness or hear any student chant build
that wall or anything hateful or racist
at any time assertions to the contrary
are simply false
our chants were loud because we wanted
to drown out the hateful comments that
were being shouted at us by the
protesters by the way the tape lines up
with this it does not line up with a
thing Philip says after a few minutes of
chanting the Native American protestors
who I hadn't previously noticed
approached our group the Native American
protesters had drums and were
accompanied by at least one person with
a camera the protestor everyone has seen
in the video began playing his drum as
he waited into the crowd which parted
for him I did not see anyone tried to
block his path he locked eyes with me
and approached me coming within inches
in my face he played his drum the entire
time he was in my face I never
interacted with this protester I did not
speak to him I did not make any hand
gestures or other aggressive moves to be
honest I was startled and confused as to
why he had approached me
we had already been yelled at by another
group of protesters and when the second
group approached I was worried that a
situation was getting out of control
where adults were attempting to provoke
teenagers I believed that by remaining
motionless and calm I was helping to
defuse the situation I realized everyone
had cameras and that perhaps a group of
adults was trying to provoke a group of
teenagers into a larger conflict I said
a silent prayer that the situation would
not get out of hand during the period of
the drumming a member of the protesters
entourage began yelling at a fellow
student that we stole our land and we
should go back to Europe I heard one of
my fellow students begin to respond I
motioned to my classmate and tried to
get him to stop engaging with the
protester as I was still in the mindset
that we needed to calm down tensions I
never felt I was blocking the Native
American protester he did not make any
attempt to go around me it was clear to
me he had singled me out for a
confrontation although I am not sure why
the engagement ended when one of our
teachers told me of the the buses had
arrived and it was time to go I obeyed
my teacher and simply walked to the
buses at that moment I thought I had to
fuse the situation by remaining calm and
I was thankful nothing physical had
happened in a second I'm going to read
you the rest of the students statement
but first I need to tell you about life
insurance so here's the reality we're
all gonna plotz and when we plus we're
gonna mount to make sure that our family
had some money right I mean that's just
if you're an adult you need life
insurance is the responsible thing to do
if you're married if it doesn't matter
you need life insurance go check it out
right now it is difficult annoying to
obtain life insurance complicated
sometimes
that's why policy genius has created a
website that makes it easy for you to
compare quotes get advice get covered
without extra fees or Commission sales
agents policy genius is the easy way to
get life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the coverage you need at a price you can
afford
from there you can apply online the
advisors of policy genius will handle
all of the red tape they'll even
negotiate your rate with the insurance
company all part of their best price
guarantee if you
intimidated or frustrated by insurance
in the past try starting your search of
policy genius.com
in minutes you can compare quotes and
apply you can do the whole thing on your
phone right now
policy genius is indeed the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance it's also
the responsible thing to do go check
them out right now at policy genius.com
again in minutes you can compare quotes
and apply you can apply online they'll
handle all the red tape for you policy
genius comm the easy way to compare and
buy life insurance okay so more from the
students who's been wrongly maligned by
the lying media his name is Nick Sandman
and he's the one who is apparently just
like accused gang rapists falsely
accused gang rapist Brett Kavanaugh for
standing there and not doing a thing but
he's a bad guy here's what he says I
never understood why either of the two
groups of protesters were engaging with
us or exactly what they were protesting
at the Lincoln Memorial we were simply
there to meet a bus not become central
players in a media spectacle this is the
first time in my life I've ever
encountered any sort of public protest
let alone this kind of confrontation or
demonstration I was not making faces at
the protestor I did smile at one point
because I wanted him to know that I was
not going to become angry intimidated or
be provoked into a larger confrontation
I'm a faithful Christian and practicing
Catholic and I always try to live up to
my ideals my faith teaches me to remain
respectful of others and to take no
action that would lead to conflict or
violence I harbor no ill will for this
person I respect this person's right to
protest and engage in free speech
activities I support his chanting on the
steps of the Lincoln Memorial any day of
the week I believe he should rethink his
tactics of invading the personal space
of others but that is his choice to make
I'm being called every name in the book
including a racist and I will not stand
for this mob-like character
assassination my family's name my
parents were not on the trip and I
strived to represent my family in a
respectful way in all public settings I
have received physical and death threats
via social media as well as hateful
insults one person threatened to harm me
at school one person claims to live in
my neighborhood my parents are receiving
death and professional threats because
of the social media mob that is formed
over this issue I love my school my
teachers and my classmates I work hard
to achieve good grades and participate
in several extracurricular activities I
am mortified that so many people have
come to believe that something that did
not happen that students from my school
were chanting or acting in a racist
fashion toward Native Americans or
African Americans I did not do that I do
not have hateful feelings in my heart I
did not witness any of my classmates
doing that I cannot speak for everyone
only for myself but I can tell you my
experience with Covington Catholic is
that students are respectful of all
races and cultures
also support everyone's right to free
speech I'm not going to comment on the
words or account of mr. Phillips as I
don't know him and would not presume to
know what it is it is in his heart of
mind nor am I going to comment further
on other protesters as I don't know
their hearts and minds either I have
read that mr. Phillips is a veteran of
the US Marines I thanked him for his
service and I'm grateful to anyone who
puts on the uniform to defend our nation
if anyone has earned the right to speak
freely it is a US Marine veteran I can
only speak for myself and what I
observed or felt at that time but I
would caution everyone passing judgment
based on a few seconds of video to watch
the longer video clips that are on the
internet as they show a much different
story than is being portrayed by people
with agendas I provided this accounts of
events to the Diocese of Cummington so
they may know exactly what happened I
stand ready and willing to cooperate
with any investigation they are
conducting that's the kid the media are
tearing down today because they are
disgusting because the members of the
media who have continued to push this
even after it's been debunked are
revolting revolting and anything I can
do to help these kids at Covington
Catholic I will do anything I can do to
help these kids who are being maligned
by the media I will do if they start a
college fund for this kid for the fornix
and man I will give money personally to
it this is it's disgusting
it said but this is what the media we're
doing that's what the media we're doing
during the march for life all the media
were concerned with many in the media I
was in many because again there are
exceptions many in the media were
concerned with finding ways not to talk
about the March for life but to
manufacture out of whole cloth stories
that fit into their wheelhouse I know
this because they also did this to me so
you may have noticed that on Friday and
Saturday trending on Twitter was the
phrase baby Hitler why was that phrase
trending on Twitter well because if you
listen to the podcast on Friday you will
know that I made a very specific
argument in which I referenced the kind
of joking offs discussed issue of would
you go back in time and kill baby Hitler
right this is this issue by the way is
not unique to me
the New York Times weren't piece on it
in 2015 we commented an on this show in
right so this is an old thing on the
Internet here is what happened there's a
guy named Jordan all a garbage human and
Jordan all took 21 seconds of my
podcasts from last week from last Friday
and he cut it out of context and then he
put it up on the internet and it got 1.2
million hits views within just minutes
because everyone on the left wants to
proclaim that I had said something crazy
at the March for life because
this fits in with their lying stupid
nonsensical false narrative that people
at the march for life aren't hair n't
leak rasie
and wild so here is the 21 second clip
that this piece of garbage knowingly cut
out of context and then put up as though
I was saying something wild out of
context here's the 21 second clip and
then you will hear the full clip and
you'll see the media ran with this story
because they were trying to manufacture
a story in order to target not really
only me but the March for Life is a
whole look at these crazy coops out
there showing up in the snowed March for
unborn babies they're all a bunch of us
here's the 21 second clip and then I
will show you the context the argument I
guess here is that would you kill baby
Hitler and the truth is that no pro-life
person on earth would kill baby Hitler
right because baby Hitler wasn't Hitler
adult Hitler was Hitler baby Hitler was
a baby and when you presumably want to
do with baby Hitler was take baby Hitler
out of baby Hitler's house and move baby
Hitler into a better house where he
would not grow up to be Hitler right
that's the idea okay and then there's a
cheer from the crap well look at these
crazy people cheering about it first of
all even out of context is the idea from
the left that you have to kill baby
Hitler I don't understand where the
controversy is even here like is the
idea that logically speaking you must
kill a baby who will grow up to be
Hitler because we live in a Minority
Report universe where you go back in
time and you get to determine what
crimes people commit before they commit
them that in and of itself is immoral
but this was not a context-free
statement I wasn't randomly discussing
the idiotic Internet baby Hitler
hypothetical I was discussing it in the
context of a very specific argument it
is an argument made in the book
Freakonomics and defended by the authors
of that book that suggests that
abortions in the 70s led to lowered
crime rates in the late 80s and early
90s and I was discussing this at length
by the way there's a quasi racist
element to this argument because
overwhelmingly or at least
disproportionately the babies being
killed in abortions in the 70s or of
minorities and poor so the idea is if
you killed poor minority unborn babies
they won't grow up to be poor minority
criminals that's pretty racist argument
okay so I was making the argument
against that here is the full context of
what I said which if you listen to last
Friday's show you will though is what I
said because you listen to the show and
you're not a media hack here was the
full context argument
abortion lowers the crime rate right
that all the that what has lowered the
crime rate traditionally has been
killing all the would-be criminals I
don't know who's comfortable with the
pre-crime version of humanity where we
get to decide before you're born whether
you're likely to be a criminal and then
abort you based on future and criminal
activity in which you have not
participated the argument I guess here
is that would you kill baby Hitler and
the truth is that no pro-life person on
earth would kill baby Hitler right
because baby Hitler wasn't Hitler adult
Hitler was Hitler baby Hitler was a baby
and would you presumably want to do with
baby Hitler was take baby Hitler out of
baby Hitler's house and move baby Hitler
into a better house where he would not
grow up to be Hitler right that's the
idea
okay the entire argument is about the
morality of killing the unborn because
you think they will commit crimes in the
future and you take the ultimate
criminal right this is called an analogy
you take the ultimate criminal and you
say this is the ultimate worst person on
earth if you knew him as a baby
you wouldn't morally be allowed to kill
him as a baby because babies are not
responsible for the actions of their
future selves instead you work to ensure
the life of the baby and then try and
bring him into the best circumstances
this is utterly uncontroversial I mean
wildly uncontroversial not only will I
double down on this I will I will
infinity down on this because this is
the easiest most clear argument there's
nothing wrong with this argument in any
way and people on the Left still have
failed to explain what is wrong with the
argument because they didn't engage with
the argument instead because I said the
phrase baby Hitler and because that's
inherently kind of funny which is sort
of the point because I said that phrase
they decided that they were going to
come after me with a hatchet hey if they
want to be the defenders of people who
kill babies go for it all yours guys all
yours but it just demonstrates once
again how wildly dishonest and
disgusting these people are I mean
disgusting there were media outlets they
took that 21 second clip I showed at the
beginning I played at the beginning a
few minutes ago they took the 21 second
clip and posted that and when I
contacted these media outlets and said
guys you might want to actually put up
like you know the full three-minute clip
so people know what I'm talking about
the media outlets would say okay you
know what you're right maybe we'll put
up the three-minute clip but we're not
gonna change the article or change the
transcript that's right because you got
clicks off it because you're liars
because if you lie and if you lie
consistently enough then people start to
believe the lie it is a so the two big
stories from the March for Life will not
be 600,000 people who showed up in the
snow to March for life the story
apparently a
according to the media were a bunch of
high school kids who are racist false
and me talking about baby Hitler which
was not even a story amazing what the
media will do to avoid talking about the
actual story then we'll get to the worst
media battery of the weekend because
this one actually has national
implications I get to that in just one
second first I got to tell you about
your window treatment your blinds okay
so the fact is that you come in your
house and you think everything around
here looks pretty nice but it still
feels kind of dingy that's because your
window coverings stink hey you need to
replace them when your window coverings
are right everything in your house looks
better more expensive but when they're
wrong it looks like you rented an
apartment on Skid Row blinds.com makes
it really easy for you to change those
window coverings you're not sure what
you want or even where to start with
blinds calm you get a free online design
consultation you send them pictures of
your house and they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme
furniture in specific rooms they'll even
send you free samples to make sure
everything looks as good in person as it
does online and every order gets free
shipping here's the best part if you
accidentally miss measure or pick the
wrong color if you make a mistake
blinds.com will remake your blinds for
free they've really made it easy for you
there's no excuse to leave up those
mangled blinds go check them out right
now for a limited time you get 20% off
everything at blinds comm when you use
promo code Ben that's blinds.com promo
code Ben for 20% off everything for wood
blinds cellular shades roller shades and
more blinds calm promo code Ben go check
them out right now blinds kaam promo
code Ben to get that special deal 20%
off everything's I'm gonna get to the
worst media battery of the weekend one
with national implications in just one
second you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire comm and subscribe to see it
live if you want to join the show live
if you want to get two hours extra this
afternoon and every afternoon live of my
show and see the video and get my show
commercial free and all of those things
all you have to do is go and subscribe
right now believe me you're gonna want
extra time with me today
I want extra time with me today my
goodness and I am like I'm in a glass
cage of emotion you want to be part of
it go check that out over at Daly
wire.com $9.99 a month or $99 a year
when you do $99 you get this the very
greatest and beverage vessels he left
his tears hot or cold tumblr filled with
tears of media members who have their
dreams shattered by the realities of
tape so go check it out the leftist
tears hot or cold tumblr also it's
almost time for our next episode of the
conversation tomorrow at 7 p.m. Eastern
4 p.m. Pacific
Andrew Clavin will be taking your
questions whew when I saw the colors
I thought it's gonna be me Andrew Clavin
will be taking your questions and
answering them live on air so get ready
to have your mind blown by the wisdom
and knowledge you've been waiting for
and get his hair curation tips as always
this episode will be free for everyone
to watch on Facebook and YouTube but
only subscribers can ask the questions
once again subscribe to get your
questions answered by andrew Clavin
tomorrow at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific and join the conversation also
subscribe over YouTube and iTunes and
all the rest will really appreciate your
support really we do because the fact is
there are too many people who don't
support reality so go support us right
now by becoming a subscriber and join
our team we're seriously grateful that
you're part of it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative radio show
and podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so the worst media battery of the
weekend was an astonishing one that the
media have decided naturally to downplay
and that is we talked about it on Friday
on the show there was there was a report
from BuzzFeed we talked about on the
radio show there's a report from
BuzzFeed suggesting that President Trump
had told Michael Cohen his personal
attorney to lied to Congress and they
said they had evidence they said that
documentary support they had text
messages they said that they knew for a
fact that Trump had told Michael Cohen
to lie right well if that's true that's
impeachable right if it's true that
there's evidence that Trump told Cohen
to commit perjury that is open
subordination of perjury and obstruction
of justice he would likely find himself
impeached if that were true or at least
he'd be in serious jeopardy of
impeachment but as it turns out BuzzFeed
is totally full of crap now when we
analyzed the article last week I talked
specifically about the holes in the
article namely they don't cite any of
the documents it's two unnamed law
enforcement officials we didn't know
what the documents actually said right
there there was a lot of vagary about
the article itself is just super long
but then something happens something
rare so robert muller himself write the
mulher team have been publicly
extraordinarily tight-lipped they've not
been talking openly about the goings-on
in the investigation it's not been
something they've talked about a lot
which is good right that's what they
should be doing it's their job to shut
up but on Friday they did something
unique on Friday night they disputed the
BuzzFeed story they came out and they
said this is just not correct here is
what Peter Carr a spokesman for molars
office said in a statement quote
BuzzFeed's description of specific
statements to the special counsels
office and characterization of documents
and testimony obtained by this office
regarding Michael Cohen's congressional
testimony are not accurate case mulher
commit in the Muller report read the
people compiling the robber molars team
over at the FBI said openly BuzzFeed is
totally full of crap totally full of it
not to them it's an unbelievable
statement because BuzzFeed was basically
claiming that the president was on his
way out there claiming his presidency
was over done finito right that was what
they were claiming and Muller came out
said wave away you guys don't worry
getting this but this ain't true how
astonishing is it that Muller himself
came out his team
out specifically and disputed our report
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
naturally BuzzFeed just stood by their
decision to publish to Ben Smith went on
CNN and with with one of his reporters
not one of his reporters who actually
was on the story right so that he was
written by two reporters Jason Leopold
and Anthony Cormier Jason Leopold has a
highly checkered history in the past as
a reporter he reported years ago Karl
Rove is gonna be indicted that turned
out not to be true
Jason Leopold didn't show up on CNN
where was he no one knew but Ben Smith
did and he explained now didn't oh well
of course we had to run with the story
yeah we're gonna publish this there are
a lot of limits around what we can say
like I think that we have said a
surprise about what we have what we have
we have some in the story we said some
things on television we've stand by all
of it but I think what we have discussed
this morning just that in the context of
the president's lawyer calling for a
leak investigation we're being extremely
careful okay so they're not gonna
explain why they're defending the story
and they're not gonna explain why
Muller's office just clock them in the
side of the head with a meat hook but
they stand by their story and then
BuzzFeed continued to say that they
stand by their reporting and they also
explained that Jason Leopold was just
away on assignment that's why he wasn't
there at CNN he was away on assignment
uh-huh
mr. solid this reporting is accurate so
the people are saying heads should roll
at BuzzFeed enough they you're hurting
the news business as a whole what do you
say I put in I've been a reporter for
twenty years my first job was on the
loading dock of the Panama City News
Herald they wouldn't give me a job
inside because I was too young and green
I've been doing this again and again and
again and again okay it's okay so they
blow the story right Muller Muller said
they I'm not saying Trump isn't saying
it it's not Trump saying on Twitter fake
news it's Muller himself saying the
story's wrong doesn't matter
CNN reported it ople BuzzFeed says it's
true and then I love this Chuck Todd
tweets out from from NBC he tweets out
that those trying to turn all media
today aren't interested in improving
journalism but protecting themselves
there's a lot more accountability in
media these days than in our politics we
know we live in a glass house we hope
the folks we cover is self-aware bull
freakin bleep bull bleep horse pucky
absolute nonsense are you kidding me the
folks in the media show me who's gonna
get
fired over this Native American story
over the over this Covington Catholic
High School story show me who's gonna
get fired
show me who's gonna get fired in the
media over taking stuff of me completely
out of context and not reporting it show
me who's gonna get fired at BuzzFeed for
Mis reporting a story the mother office
says they got wrong
show me the person she went person to
get suspended show me the person who
even gets ripped forget about suspended
forget about dismissed
show me the person who even get studded
show me the correction at the bottom of
the story there will be none none it's
unreal it's unreal so you won't you
wonder why people in the media are not
trusted by the American people maybe
because they promote lies for their own
political point of view and I'll give
you another example with them hey so
when I say that the media have a bunch
of narratives and they seek to promote
those narratives at every available
opportunity I mean it so let's look up
some headlines about the women's March
okay so the women's March took place on
Saturday and nine people showed up right
no no like really then the number of
people who showed up for the women's
March was significantly lower than the
number of people who showed up for the
for the pro-life march that we were at
on Friday and the women's March received
significantly more TV coverage than the
March for Life according to media
reaches Research Center the 2019 women's
March which again had nine people there
received roughly 15 times more news
coverage than the 47th March for life on
broadcast television shocker and the
only coverage of the March for Life has
received on television at all has been
my comments about why you should not
slaughter the unborn on the basis of
suspicion of future crime and a bunch of
high school students being lied about by
the national media the 2019 women's
March fetched 14 minutes and 26 seconds
of coverage between Wednesday morning
and Saturday evening as opposed to 58
seconds for the March for Life where by
the way the vice-president personally
appeared and the President of the United
States appeared via tape it's amazing
okay and and did anybody actually
mention did anybody actually mention the
actual story the Marshall life no so I'm
looking right now at let's look at
Google News for the March for life so
I'm doing this in real-time
okay so we'll see it says represent US
women's March returns amid controversy
over anti-semitism and it says for women
on what the 2019 women's March was like
that's from the cut
Elva calm all the best signs from the 29
women's March and then this one from the
Vox planers the 2019 women's March
battled controversy these women turned
out anyway I look at the heroism and
then the Washington Post women's March
has always been divisive here's how we
can fix it the so what was the actual
story from the women's March it wasn't
that they were sort of plagued by
controversy it was that at the women's
March Linda Sarsour who is one of the
chairman of the wheelchair women of the
women's March got up and openly called
for a boycott of the State of Israel
which is based anti-semitism she called
for it from the podium and people
cheered I'm looking at the headlines
from Google there is not a single
headline on Google News about what Linda
Sarsour said at the top of the search
for women's March not one not one okay
it's astonishing here's what she said so
there she is saying that we should we
should be in favor of big s now the way
that these activists couches we're in
favor of the right to boycott you have
the right to boycott in the United
States you just can't get a federal
contract if you do just like you can't
get a federal contract if you racially
discriminate against black people and
but there she is being cheered from the
podium for doing this routine Tameka
Mallory by the way one of the chair
women of the event she was asked by
Margaret Hoover last week whether Israel
should exist okay there's no again this
is just base root anti-semitism
here's Tameka Mallory explaining Israel
does not have a right to exist as a
nation your view that Israel has a right
to exist as a nation I have said many
times that I feel everyone has a right
to exist I feel everyone has a right to
exist I just don't feel that anyone has
a right to exist at the disposal of
another group in your view does not
include Israelis in Israel I believe
that all people have the right to exist
and that Palestinians are also suffering
with a great crisis I'm done talking
about this okay Kim okay I just don't
think it requires scholarly knowledge to
be able to say that Israel has a right
to exist it's it again I believe
everyone has the right to
exist and then she said everyone has the
right to exist but not at the expense of
someone else I guess she's pro-life now
so that's that's good to know then
Alexander Ocasio Court has showed up at
the March at the Women's March and she
was asked specifically about
anti-semitism did she have an answer for
that
no Alex from the Bronx she of the
diverse background and Jewish heritage
supposedly no of course notes all that
Trump within the women's March well
first of all I think that right now in
this moment in in the United States we
have to Center this conversation I think
that concerns of anti-semitism with the
current administration in the White
House are absolutely valid and we need
to make sure that we are protecting the
Jewish community and all those that feel
vulnerable in this moment okay so it's
about Trump so the heads of the women's
March are on the podium calling for
boycott of Israel and it's all about
Trump now did the media report a lot of
this f no of course not because that's
not relevant they'll talk about the
general problem of anti-semitism with
the women's March you know it's
controversial do they report the
specific comments of Linda Sarsour at
the top of Google News no of course not
did they report the Native American
situation or the baby Hitler thing at
the top of Google you bet they did of
course they did because this is what
they always do this is what they do
every single time it's unreal it's
unreal so it's just amazing amazing
stuff but you know this is this is why
people don't trust the media and this is
why when president from bangs on the
media everybody on the right nods along
because we know they're lying to us it's
all about pressing the narrative it is
not a single little bit about the truth
and it's also why President Trump is
likely to ignore media narratives when
it comes to actual policymaking
because he knows as do we all the media
have an agenda I said on CNN years ago
that right as Trump was becoming
president that they should focus less on
narrative and more on fact right if they
just want to report facts and leave the
opinion outside the facts then maybe we
could actually have a conversation but
they don't want to do that what they
want to do is press forward an agenda
and you know I've spent honest-to-god
I've spent the last couple of years
really working on trying to see people
who don't agree with me as if they are
speaking in good faith and I've always
tried to do this really I've tried to
I've spent a lot of my life trying to
see people on the other side as people
of good faith and I was willing to give
people
the doubt on that over the past 72 hours
I got to tell you my opinion on this has
shifted a little bit because I can't
grant you the premise of good faith when
you act an openly bad faith when you act
when you promulgate lies for political
purposes because it serves your
narrative if you do that you're not
acting in good faith anymore and this is
not directed at every member of the
media again it's not directed at every
member of the left again but if you were
promulgating these lies after they had
been debunked about these kids if you
were promulgating the BuzzFeed story
after Muller came out against it if you
were promulgating the baby Hitler
controversy after it was obvious that it
was a non traversée that no one cared
and that it was a sheer political hit if
you were doing any of that stuff you
weren't acting in good faith and more
than that if you knew that these were
bad hits and you didn't speak up this
makes you complicit if you knew these
were bad hits and you stood there and
you continue to maintain that they were
good hits or you just stood there and
stood aside and you wouldn't defend
these kids or you wouldn't defend Trump
against the BuzzFeed story after Muller
debunked it there's nothing I can I
can't Brent you that I can't grant you
the benefit of the doubt you lose
benefit of the doubt okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like let me
remind you there was this thing called
the March for life that happened on
Friday that the media largely ignored in
favor of these other two narratives that
were shared garbage and it was one of
the great moments I have to say was one
of the great moments of my of my public
life I thought it was an unbelievable
showing you know probably six somewhere
between I don't know five and ten
thousand people showed up for the live
podcast on Friday which was just
wonderful and then hundreds of thousands
of people showed up to the March for
Life speech so people who listen to the
podcast I'm sure you know heard my
comments during the podcast cuz it was
the podcast but they may not have heard
my March for Life speech so here in its
entirety was the speech that I gave at
the March for life on Friday in front of
probably a couple of hundred thousand
people what an amazing event
what an amazing showing for life thank
you all for being here America's story
is an incredible story it's the story of
a shining ideal pursued over the
centuries extended to the full range and
scope of humanity America was founded on
the promise of god-given rights chief
among them the rights to life and
liberty
now while America may have imperfectly
imperfectly fulfilled that promise we
always move for
toward the perfection of that promise
over time those unjustly omitted from
the founding bargain were admitted and
embraced the American family grew only
one group was left behind that group had
once been the most prized possession of
a great and moral people its children
the souls entrusted to us by the Creator
given to us with care and love we built
the country for our children we built
our lives for our children and then
something happened we as a country
decided to erase them we decided that
the president was more important than
the future we decided that convenience
was more important than basic decency we
decided that we could safely blot out
millions of souls who could not protect
themselves still forever voices that
could not speak Ouija humanized the most
human the most innocent among us we lied
to ourselves and then we built walls
around that lie we lied about the
science we falsified anti scientific
arguments about the origin of life we
pretended that human beings were not
actually human beings we pretended that
human beings with DNA different from
their fathers and their mothers human
beings producing their own red blood
cells by 12 weeks their own fingerprints
by week 8 their own developing eyes legs
and hands by week 5 their own forming
nervous systems by week 3 we pretended
that these were not human beings human
lives at all but disposable balls of
meat we fought to avoid looking directly
at the ugly truth of what we had done we
created euphemisms termination of
pregnancy abortion choice what we're
really engaging in was the mass killing
of the unborn of course millions of
children who had never beheld who had
never opened their eyes who would never
see the Sun Rise who had never become
parents and then grandparents the
dismemberment of babies in the womb the
torture of tiny bodies and we told
ourselves that we were virtuous for our
lie we reversed good and evil we told
ourselves that the killing had to
continue because if it didn't we'd be
disadvantaged in women or raising crime
rates or imposing economic hardship we
young woman that abortion wasn't merely
a choice it was a valuable worthwhile
choice we told them to shout their
abortion to be proud of participating in
the killing of the unborn
we excised those who stood for life
Governor Andrew Cuomo of New York said
just a few years ago that those who are
right to live quote have no place in the
state of New York
just this week Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau said the pro-lifers were
not in line with quote where we are as a
society well you know what maybe they're
right maybe we today here are not in
line with Society we do live in a time
when the Democratic Party has embraced
in bortion as a sacrament and by the way
a time when many in the Republican Party
spent years pledging to defund Planned
Parenthood and then didn't do it when
they were given the power to do so we
live in a time when pro-life nations
around the world are loosening their own
restrictions on the killing of the
unborn so perhaps we are out of line
with the rest of society to which I say
good so were the abolitionists so were
the civil rights marchers so are the
martyrs in Rome and the Jews in Egypt
righteousness doesn't have to be popular
it just has to be righteous and so we
march we march for those who can't the
media will ignore us because they always
do they'll cover other marches you know
the five people who show up tomorrow
they'll cover the marshes they prefer
politically they bet that the tens of
thousands of us who brave the cold every
year to stand here with the souls of the
future America will be forgotten we will
not be forgotten
our children slaughtered over the
decades
remember they look at us from above and
they know that they meant something that
they do mean something so long as we
keep them in our minds and in our hearts
our children standing here with us the
ones who are here today they will
remember - they will remember and they
will march until they no longer have to
march our children yet unborn will
remember and they will thank us in their
prayers and most of all God the God who
built and preserves nations who bring
his life and maintains it who stands
with those who suffer most at the hands
of evil he will remember us - he will
remember America and he will bless her
God will bless us because we are the
guardians of his most precious creations
we stand between America and the
darkness and we will march until that
darkness is banished forever and all of
our children can stand together in the
sunlight thank you so much
so that's the speech that people didn't
report what they reported instead was a
21 second clip taken by a progressive
activist who's determined to try and
come after our show that's that's that's
what they'll report it's a well done
media you guys did a wonderful job other
things I like I should mention
congratulations to particularly my
production team it was an amazing job
every day on the show I mean they made
the stuff at the march for life happened
they're really amazing we did win the
best news podcast over at the I Heart
Radio Awards on Friday night so that's
pretty exciting stuff we were the best
news podcast we defeated other shows
with different viewpoints I won't
mention names like pod save America we
did actually win an award so that was
fun and you know what there's been
enough anger on the show today so I'm
gonna skip the things that I hate I'll
save it for probably later today so if
you are a subscriber than later today
you can actually watch me go off I've
much more to talk about but
unfortunately we've run our time limit
here you can go check us out over at
daily wire comm for $9.99 a month and
there'll be two more hours of this I
have a lot more to get to this afternoon
we will see you then or we'll see you
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19